one year from today voters will go to
the polls for the crucial midterm
elections but the two major parties are
already in a fight that could tilt the
scales before any votes are cast it's a
process called gerrymandering that's a
term that dates back to 1812
when massachusetts governor elbridge
jerry drew this district around boston
and the local paper said it looked like
a salamander hence gerrymander the name
stuck now despite reforms to end the
practice ed o'keefe shows us how both
parties are trying to gain an advantage
in two very different states ed good
morning to you a gerrymander almost
looks quaint compared to what they're
drawing these days it sure does tony
good morning happy one year to go until
election day 2022
dozens of states are still redrawing
their lines some fights are so
contentious they're likely to end up in
court and may not get decided until
closer to election day next year we
recently visited two states new york and
ohio at the center of these kinds of
fights ones controlled completely by
democrats the other by republicans both
solid examples of the kinds of partisan
games being played nationwide
this fall in ohio state's sea of red
there's also a red blue divide that's
harder to see the university home to
more than 60 thousand students is sliced
up into three different congressional
districts one so large it links part of
ohio state's columbus campus with ohio
university an hour and a half away in
appalachia you look at the state map and
you want to laugh it looks like a
kindergartner drew it
heather pearson lives in this little
part of columbus that sticks out on the
congressional map like a sore thumb
basically we feel like we're being
ignored it's done so our votes don't
count right here this side is one
congressional district jen miller who
leads ohio's non-partisan league of
women voters
came with us to walk the line do they
look house by house at how people are
registered they do in fact there are
literally situations in ohio where one
house can be surrounded on three sides
by another congressional district
literally it is map makers and
politicians picking their voters rather
than the other way around
overall ohio voters pick republicans
just slightly more than democrats in
recent congressional elections but look
at this map 12 of the state's 16 house
seats are republican controlled in part
because the gop controls state
government and drew the lines and
they're doing this why simply to secure
a partisan advantage miller's group is
suing the ohio redistricting commission
also controlled by republicans alleging
extreme partisan gerrymandering we asked
to talk to those republicans but they
all declined an interview the columbus
powers so we turned a longtime ohio gop
strategist terry casey to those that say
republicans are drawing these lines the
way they want in order to hold on to
power you would say welcome to america
and politics be in politics that's just
the way the game is played until the
supreme court or somebody else figures
out a better way
a better way is also what new yorkers
asked for backing a bipartisan
commission but in the empire state
democrats could use their total control
in the state legislature to reject the
commission's map and draw their own one
proposal could cost republicans up to
five seats in congress it's just not
something that captures the public's
attention we joined democratic state
senator michael gianaris who could get
to draw those lines on a walk-through
part of queens represented by
congresswoman alexandria ocasio-cortez
that could get drawn out of her district
for you guys you'd have to memorize a
whole new map every 10 years potentially
and we do across the street from my home
is somebody else's senate district so i
have neighbors of mine that to this day
are confused that they don't get to vote
for me and confused to find his name
still on the side of his former office
here his former office because
republicans drew it out of his district
a decade ago as a form of political
punishment now giannaris says new york
needs a better way
even if it costs his party some power
the goal is to set up a commission
that's really independent and is not
colored by the politics who would be
qualified to serve on an independent
commission it's difficult obviously
priests and surgeons i mean and then who
gets to choose those people right back
in ohio jen miller agrees it's absolute
human instinct if your party is in power
to use that to rig a political advantage
for the next decade and so i think the
only option is to take political parties
and candidates out of the process
because they're always going to want to
rig them
so 44 states are redrawing their lines
because of population changes 11 are
done 33 still to go as we said some of
them may end up in court fights notably
last week new york voters rejected one
plan that might have made their
independent commission a little more
independent but unless someone else
comes up with a better way or the courts
force them to do so tony these games are
going to continue
wow and high stakes games very
eye-opening piece just because both
sides do it doesn't make it right
unfortunately
thank you